PATRICK WINSTON: Today
we're going to be
talking about Search.
I know you're going to
turn blue with yet
another lecture on Search.
Those of you who are taking
computer science subjects,
you've probably seen in 601.
You'll see it again
as theory course.
But we're going to do it for
a little different purpose.
I want you to develop some
intuition about various kinds
of Search work.
And I want to talk a little bit
about Search as a model of
what goes on in our heads.
And toward the end, if there's
time, I'd like to do a
demonstration for you of
something never before
demonstrated to a 603.4 class,
because it was only completed
last spring.
And some finishing touches were
added by me this morning.
Always dangerous, but we'll
see what happens.
There's Cambridge.
You all recognize
it, of course.
You might want to get from some
starting position s to
some goal position g.
So, you'll hire a cab and
hope for the best.
So, here's what might
happen, not too hot.
Let's move the starting
position over here.
I've had cab drivers
like this New York.
But it's not a very good path.
It's the path of a thief.
Let's change the way that the
search is done to that of a
beginner, an honest beginner.
Not too bad.
Now, let's have a look at how
the Search would happen if the
cab driver was a Ph.D.
in physics
after his third post-doc.
These are not actually
traverse.
These are just things that the
driver is thinking about, and
that is the very best of
all possible paths.
So, the thief does
a horrible job.
The beginner does a pretty
good job, but
not an optimal job.
This is the optimal job as
produced by the Ph.D. in
physics after his
third post-doc.
So, would you like to understand
how those all work?
The answer, of course, is yes.
I'm going to talk to you about
procedures that are different
from the way that you just
solved this problem.
I imagine that if I said to you,
please find a path for s
to g, you would, within
a few seconds, find
a pretty good path--
not the optimal one, but
a pretty good one--
using your eyes.
And we're not going to tell
you about how that works,
because we don't know
how that works.
But we do know that problem
solving with the eyes is an
important part of our
total intelligence.
And we'll never have a complete
theory of human
intelligence until we can
understand the contributions
of the human visual system to
solving everyday problems like
finding a pretty good
path in that map.
But, alas, we can't talk about
that, because we don't know
how to do it.
We're working on it.
But we don't know
how to do it.
So, I'm not going to use
Cambridge in my illustrations.
There's too much there to
work through in an hour.
So, we're going to use this map
over here which has been
designed to illustrate a
few important points.
You, too, can find a path
through that graph pretty
easily with your eyes.
Our programs don't have eyes,
and they don't have visually
grounded algorithms, so they're
going to have to do
something else.
And the very first kind of
search we want to talk about
is called the British
Museum approach.
This is a slur against at least
the British Museum, if
not the entire nation, because
the way you do a British
Museum search is you find
every possible path.
So, it'll be helpful to have a
diagram of all possible paths
on the board.
We're going to start with
a British Museum search.
From the starting position, it's
clear, you can go from my
s to either a or b.
And already there's an
important quiz point.
Whenever we have these kinds of
problems on a quiz, we ask
you to develop the tree
associated with a search in
lexical order.
So, the nodes there under s
are listed alphabetically,
just to have an orderly
way of doing it.
So, from a we can go
either b or d.
And another convention of the
subject, another thing you
have to keep in mind in quizzes,
is it we don't have
these searches bite
their own tail.
So, I could have said that
if I'm at a, I can
also go back to s.
But no path is ever allowed
them to bite itself, to go
around and enter and get
back to a place that's
already on the path.
Now if I go on to b first, that
means that from b I can
go to either a or c.
This is getting fat
pretty fast.
But let's see, s, a, b.
The only place I can go
is c and then to e.
s, a, d, without biting my own
tail and going back to a, the
only place I can go is g.
s b, a, I can only go
to d and then to g.
And finally, s, b, c,
I can only go to e.
So, that is a complete set of
paths as produced by any
program that you will feel you'd
like to write that finds
all possible paths.
I haven't been very precise
about how to do that, because
you don't have to be.
You can't save much work by
being clever, because you have
to find everything.
So, that's the British Museum
expansion of the tree.
So, what have I done?
I've been playing around
with a map.
I showed you an example
of a map.
And pretty soon you're
going to think that
Search is about maps.
So, before going even another
tiny step, I want to emphasize
that Search is not
equal to maps.
Search is about choice.
And I happen to illustrate
these searches with maps,
because they are particularly
cogent.
But Search is not about maps.
It's about the choices you make
when you're trying to
make decisions.
These things I'm going to be
talking to you about today are
choices you make when
you explore the map.
You can make other kinds of
choices when you're exploring
other kinds of things.
And, in fact, at the end, if
there's time, I'll show you
how you do searches when you're
solving problems in a
humanities class.
That's the British
Museum algorithm.
Search is not about maps.
Our first gold star idea,
Search is about choice.
But for our illustration,
Search is about maps.
So, the first kind of Search we
want to talk about that's
real is Depth-first Search.
And the idea of Depth-first
Search is that you barrel
ahead in a single-minded way.
So, from s, your choices
are a or b.
And you always go down the left
branch by convention.
So, from s, we go to a.
From a we have two choices.
We can go to either b or
d following our lexical
convention.
After that, we can go to c.
And after that we can go to e.
And too bad for us,
we're stuck.
What are we going to do.
We've got into a dead
end, all is lost.
But of course, all isn't lost.
Because we have the choice of
backing up to the place where
we last made a decision and
choosing another branch.
So, that process is called
variously back-up or
backtracking.
At this point, we would
say, ah, dead end.
The first place we find when we
back up the tree where we
made a choice is when we
chose b instead of d.
So, we go back up there and
take the other route.
s, a, d now goes to g.
And we're done.
We're going to make up a little
table here of things
that we can embellish our
basic searches with.
And one of the things we can
embellish our basic searches
with is this backtracking
idea.
Now, backtrack is not relevant
to the British Museum
algorithm, because you've
got to find everything.
You can't quit when you've
found one path.
But you'd always want to use
backtracking with Depth-first
Search, because you may plunge
on down and miss the path that
gets to the goal.
Now, you might ask me, is
backtracking, therefore,
always part of Depth-first
Search?
And you can read textbooks
that do it either way.
Count on it.
If we give you a Search problem
on a quiz, we'll tell
you whether or not your Search
is supposed to use
backtracking.
We consider it to be
an optional thing.
You'd be pretty stupid not to
use this optional thing when
you're doing Depth-first
Search.
But we'll separate these
ideas out and call
it an optional add-on.
so, that's Depth-first
Search, very simple.
Now, the natural companion to
Depth-first Search will be
Breadth-first Search,
Breadth-first.
And the way it works is you
build up this tree level by
level, and at some point, when
you scan across a level,
you'll find that you've
completed a path
that goes to the goal.
So, level by level, s can
go to either a or b.
a can go either to b or d.
And b can go to either a or c.
So, you see what we're doing.
We're going level by level.
And we haven't hit a level
with a goal in it yet, so
we've got to keep going.
Note that we're building up
quite a bit of stuff here,
quite a lot of growth in the
size of the path set that
we're keeping in mind.
At the next level, we have b
going to c, d going to g, a
going to d, and c going to e.
And now, when we scan
across, we do hit g.
So, we found a path with
Breadth-first Search, just as
we found a path with
Depth-first Search.
Now, you might say, well,
why didn't you just quit
when you hit g?
Implementation detail.
We'll talk about a sample
implementation.
You can write it in
any way you want.
But now that we know what these
searches are, let's
speed things up a little bit
here and do a couple searches
that now have names.
The first type will be
Depth-first, boom.
That's the one that produces
the thief path.
And then we can also do a
Breadth-first Search, which we
haven't tried yet.
What do you suppose is
going to happen?
Is it going to be fast, slow,
produce a good path,
produce a bad path?
I don't know, let's try it.
I had to speed it up, you see,
because it's doing an awful
lot of Search.
It's generating an awful
lot of paths.
Finally, you got a path.
Is it the best path?
I don't think so.
But we're not going to talk
about optimal paths today.
We're just going to talk
about pretty good
paths, heuristic paths.
Let's move the starting position
here in the middle.
Do you think Breadth-first
Search is going to be stupid?
I think it's going to
be pretty stupid.
Let's see what happens.
This Search is a lot to the
left, which you would never do
with you eye.
Let me slow that down just
to demonstrate it.
It finds a shorter path, because
it's right there in
the middle.
But it spends a lot of its time
looking off to the left.
It's pretty stupid.
But that's how it works.
So, now that we've got two
examples of searches on the
table, I'd like to just write
a little flow chart for how
the search might work.
Because if I do that, then it'll
be easier for us to see
what kind of small differences
there are between the
implementations of these
various searches.
So, what we're going to do is
we're going to develop a
waiting list, a queue, a
line, whatever you'd
like to call it.
Let's call if a queue.
We're going to develop a queue
of paths that are under
consideration.
So, the first step in our
algorithm will be to
initialize our queue.
And I think what I'll do is
I'll simulate Depth-first
Search on this problem
up there on the
left using this algorithm.
I need to have some way of
representing my paths.
And what I want to do is I'm
going to betray my heritage as
a list programmer, because I'm
just going to put these up as
if there were lisp
s-expressions.
To begin with, I just
have one path.
And it has only one
node in it, s.
That's the whole path.
The next thing I do after I
initialize the queue is I
extend first path
on the queue.
OK, when I extend s,
I get two paths.
I get s goes to a, and
I get s goes to b.
I take the first one off
the front of the queue.
And I put back the two
that are produced by
extending that path.
Now, after I've extended the
first path on the queue, I
have to but those extended
paths on to the queue.
In here there's an explicit step
where I've checked to see
if that first path
is a winner.
If it's not, I extend it.
And I have to put those
paths onto the queue.
So, I'll say that what
I do is I end queue.
Now, I've done one step.
And let's let me do
another step.
I'm going to take this
first path off.
I'm going to extend that path.
And where do I put these new
paths on the queue if I'm
doing Depth-first Search?
Well, I want to work with the
path that I've just generated.
I'm taking this plunge down
deep into the search tree.
So, since I want to keep going
down into the stuff that I
just generated, where then do I
want to put these two paths?
At the end of the queue?
I don't think so, because
it'll be a long
time getting there.
I want to put them on the
front of the queue.
For Depth-first Search, I
want to put them on the
front of the queue.
And that's why s, a, b goes
here, and s, a, d, and then
that's s, b.
So, s, b is still there.
That's still a valid
possibility.
But now I've stuck two paths
in front of it, both of the
ones I generated by taking a
path off the front of the
queue, discovering that it
doesn't go to the goal,
extending it and putting those
back on the queue.
I might as well complete
this illustration here.
While I'm at it, I take the s,
a, b off, s, a, b, and I can
go only there to c.
But, of course, I keep s, a,
d and s, b on the queue.
Now, I take the front off the
queue again, and I get s, a,
b, c, e, and not to forget
s, a, d and s, b.
I take the first one
off the queue.
It doesn't go to the goal.
I try to extend it, but
there's nothing there.
I've reached a dead end.
So, in this operation, all I'm
doing is taking the front one
off the queue and shortening
the queue.
We're almost home.
I take s, a,d off of queue.
And I get s, a, d, c.
And, of course, I
still have s, b.
Now, the next time I visit the
situation, buried in that
first step, I discover a path
that actually does get to
goal, and I'm done.
So, each time around I
visualize the queue.
I check to see if I'm done.
If not, I take the extensions
and put them
somewhere on the queue.
And then I go back in.
And then here there's a varied
test which checks to see if
we're done.
That's how the Depth-first
Search algorithm works.
And now, would we have to start
all over again if we did
Breadth-first Search?
Nope.
Same algorithm.
All the code we've got
needs one line
replaced, one line changed.
What do I have to do different
in order to get a
Breadth-first Search out
of this instead of
a Depth-first Search?
Tanya?
TANYA: Change [INAUDIBLE]
on the queue.
PATRICK WINSTON: And where
do I put it on the queue?
She says to change it.
TANYA: On the back?
PATRICK WINSTON: Put
it on the back.
So, with Breadth-first Search
all I have to do
is put on the back.
Now, if we were content with a
inefficient search, and didn't
care much about how good our
path was, we'd be done.
And we could go home.
But we are a little concerned
about the
efficiency of our search.
And we would like a
pretty good path.
So, we're going to have
to stick around
for a little while.
Now, you may have noticed, up
there in that the development
of the Breadth-first Search,
that the algorithm is
incredibly stupid.
Why is the algorithm
incredibly stupid?
Ty, what do you think?
TY: It can't tell whether it's
getting closer or further away
from the goal.
PATRICK WINSTON: It certainly
can't tell whether it's
getting closer or further
away from the goal.
And we're going to deal
with that in a minute.
But it's even stupider
than that.
Why is it stupid?
What's your name?
DYLAN: Dylan.
It [? hits ?] the same
nodes twice.
PATRICK WINSTON: Dylan said it's
extending paths that go
to the same node
more than once.
Let's see what Dylan's
talking about.
Down here, it extends a.
But it's already extended
a up there.
Down here, it extends a
path that goes to b.
And it's already extended
a path that goes to d.
Over here, it could extend a
path that went through c, but
it's already got a path
that goes through c.
So, all of these paths
are duplicated.
And we're still going
through them.
That's incredibly stupid.
What we're going to do is
we're going to amend our
algorithm just a little bit.
And we're not going to extend
the first path on the queue
unless final node never
before extended.
What we're going to do is we're
going to look to see if
there-- we've got this path.
And we're going to extend it.
And it's got a final note.
If we've ever extended a path
that goes to that final node,
and it was a final node on
that path, then we're not
going to do it again.
We got to keep a list of places
that have already been
the last piece of a path
that was extended.
Everybody got that?
It's a little awkward to say it,
because it's the last node
we care about.
If a path terminates in a node,
and if some other path
previously terminated in that
node and got extended--
we're not going to
do it again.
Because it's a waste of time.
Now, let's see if this
actually helps.
Now, use the extended list.
Let's see, well, gee,
we got that place
in the center there.
Let's just repeat the
previous search.
Wow, it's taking a long time.
But notice it put 103 paths
back on the queue.
Now, let's add a filter
and try again.
A lot less.
So, let's speed this up, and
we'll start way over here.
You remember how tedious
that search was.
And now we'll repeat it with
this list, boom, there it is.
That's all because we didn't do
that silly thing of going
back through the final
node that's
already been gone through.
So, you would never not
want to do this.
We better list this
as another option.
It doesn't help with a British
Museum algorithm, because
nothing helps with the British
Museum algorithm.
Does it help with Depth-first?
Yes.
Does it help with
Breadth-first?
Yes.
Do we do backtracking
with Breadth-first?
No, because backtracking
can't do us any good.
OK, we're almost, except that
search that's starting in the
middle is still pretty stupid.
Both the Breadth-first version
and the Depth-first version
are going off to the left.
And we would never do that with
our eyes in any case.
The next thing we want to do is
we want to have ourselves a
slightly more informed search
by taking into consideration
whether we seem to be
getting anywhere.
So, in general, it's a good
thing to get closer to where
we want to go.
In general, if we've got a
choice of going to a node
that's close to the goal or a
node that's not so close to
the goal, we'll always want
to go to the one that's
close to the goal.
And as soon as we add that to
what we're doing, we have
another kind of Search,
which goes by the
name of Hill Climbing.
And it's just like Depth-first
Search, except instead of
using lexical order to break
ties, we're going to break
ties according to which node
is closer to the goal.
I went to some trouble
to talk to you about
this enqueued list.
And having gone to that
trouble, I'm now
going to ignore it.
Not because it isn't a good
idea, but because trying to
keep track of everything
in the example is
confusing the example.
It won't work out right in the
small example and all that.
Put the queueing thing aside,
queued list aside, and think
instead just about the value
of going in the direction
that's getting us closer
to the goal.
In Hill Climbing Search, just
like a Depth-first Search, we
have a and b.
And we're still going to list
them lexically on underneath
the parent node.
But now which one is so
closer to the goal?
Now, this time b is closer
to the goal than a.
So, instead of following the
Depth-first course, which
would take us down through a,
we're going to go to the one
that's closest which
goes through b.
And b can either go to a or c.
b is six units away from the
goal. a is about seven plus,
not drawn exactly to scale.
Use the numbers not your eyes.
Now where are we?
It's symmetric, so a and
c are both equally
far from the goal.
Now we're going to use
the lexical order
to break the tie.
Now from s, b, a,
we'll go to d.
And now, which is closest
to the goal?
That's the only choice
we have.
So, now we have no choice but
to go down to the goal.
That's the Hill Climbing way
of doing the search.
And notice that this time
there's no backtracking.
It's not the optimal path.
It's not the best path.
But at least there's
no backtracking.
That's not always true.
That's just an artifact of
this particular example.
Do you think Hill Climbing would
produce a faster search?
I think so.
Let's see what happens
when we add these
things at one at a time.
First, let's turn off
our extended list.
We turned off our
extended list.
And we're going to do
Depth-first again just for the
sake of comparison.
It produces a very roundabout
path with 48 enqueueings.
Now, let's switch over
to Hill Climbing.
And what do think?
Do you think it will produce
a straighter path, fewer
enqueueings?
Boom.
You wouldn't not want to
do that, would you?
If you've got some kind of
heuristic that tells you that
you're getting close to the
goal, you should use it.
Now, it's easy to modify my
example over there so that
getting close to the goal
gets you trapped in a
blind alley on e.
That's easy to do.
But that's just an artifact
of the example.
In general, you want to go along
a path that gets you
closer to the goal.
So, that's 23.
I don't know, let's see if using
the extended list filter
does any good.
Yeah, still 23.
So, in that particular case
the extension list didn't
actually do us any good, because
we're driving so
directly toward the goal.
OK, that's that.
Now, let's see, is there
any analog to--
well, we might say that this
is yet another way of
distinguishing the searches.
And that is, is it an
informed search?
Is it making use of any kind
of heuristic information?
Certainly, a British Museum
is not, Depth is
not, Breadth is not.
And now let's consider what
we got for Hill Climbing.
Do we want to use
backtracking?
Sure.
Do we want to use an
enqueued list?
Sure.
And it is informed, because it's
taking advantage of this
extra information.
It may not be in your problem.
It's not often the case you've
got this information in a map.
Your problem may not have any
heuristic measurement of
distance to the goal.
In which case, you
can't do it.
But if you've got it,
you should use it.
Oh, yeah, there's one more.
And I've already given it away
by having it on my chart.
It's called Beam Search.
And just as Hill Climbing is
an analog of Depth-first
Search, Beam Search is a
complement or addition of an
informing heuristic to
Breadth-first Search.
What you do is you start
off just like
Breadth-first Search.
But you say I'm going to limit
the number of paths I'm going
to consider at any level to
some small, fixed number,
like, in this case,
how about two.
So, I'm going to say that
I have a Beam of
two for my Beam Search.
Otherwise, I proceed just
like Breadth-first
Search, b, d, a, g.
And now I've got that stupid
thing where I'm duplicating my
nodes, because I'm forgetting
about the enqueued list.
But to illustrate Beam Search,
what about I'm going to do now
is I'm going to take all these
paths I've got at the second
level, and I'm only going
to keep the best two.
That's my beam width.
And the best two are the two
that get closest to the goal.
So, those four, b, c, a,
and d, which two get
closest to the goal?
Now, b and d.
These guys are trimmed off.
I'm only keeping two
at every level.
Now, going down from b and
d, I have, at the next
level, c and g.
And now I've found the goal.
So, I'm done.
We could do that here, too.
We could choose a Beam
Search, not bad.
Let's see, let's try this
thing from the middle.
Let's slow my speed
down a little bit.
Now, are we going to see
anything going off to the left
like we did with ordinary
Breadth-first Search?
No, because it's smart.
It doesn't say, I want to go to
a place that's further away
from my goal.
Now, let's see, maybe we can go
back to our algorithm now
and talk about that enqueueing
mechanism and
talk about Hill Climbing.
Can I use the same basic search
mechanism, just change
that one line again?
Yes.
How do I add new paths to
the queue this time?
Well, it's very much like
Hill Climbing, right?
I want to add them
to the front but
with one little flourish.
What's the flourish?
[? Krishna, ?] what
do you think?
Remember, I want to use my
heuristic information.
So, I not only add them to the
front, but amongst the ones
I'm adding to the front,
what do I do?
AUDIENCE:Check the distance?
PATRICK WINSTON: Check
the distance.
And how do you arrange them?
AUDIENCE:[? You ?]
[? keep the ?] minimum
[? first. ?]
PATRICK WINSTON: Yeah, you
can put the minimum
first if you like.
But let's sort them.
We'll sort them, that will
keep everything straight.
So Hill Climbing is
front-sorted.
And, finally, how about Beam?
What do we do with Beam Search
to add them to the queue?
Well, it doesn't matter where we
add them, because all we're
going to do is we're going
to keep the w best.
So, with Beam, we'll just
abbreviate that by
saying keep w best.
Now, you have some of the basic
searches in you're toolkit.
There's one more that's
sometimes talked about.
We've got Depth, Breadth, Best,
and Beam, one more is
Best, Best-first Search.
It's a variant where you say,
I've got this tree.
It's got a bunch of paths that
terminate in leaves.
Let me just always work on
the leaf node that's
closest to the goal.
It can skip around a little bit
from one place to another.
Because as it pursues one path,
it may not do very well
in some other path
quite distant.
And the tree will become
the best one.
We've actually seen an instance
of that in then
integration program.
It's capable of skipping all
over the place, because it's
always taking the easiest
problem in the search tree, in
the and/or tree, working
on that.
That's Best-first Search.
You can do these sorts
of things in
continuous spaces, too.
And you've done the
mathematics of
that in 1802 or something.
But in continuous spaces, the
Hill Climbing sometimes leads
to problems or doesn't
do very well.
What kind of a problem can you
encounter in a continuous
space with Hill Climbing?
Well, how would you do
Hill Climbing in
a continuous space?
Let's say we're in the
mountains, and a big
fog has come up.
We're trying to get to the
top of the hill before
we freeze to death.
And we take a few steps north,
a few steps east, west, and
south using our compass.
And we check to see which
direction seems to be doing
the best job of getting
us moving upward.
And that's our Hill Climbing
approach, right?
We have explored four directions
we can go and pick
the best one.
And from there, we pick four,
try all those, pick the best
one, and away we go.
We've got ourselves a Hill
Climbing algorithm.
What's wrong with it?
Or what can be wrong with it?
Sometimes it works just fine.
Yes.
SPEAKER 1: You might get stuck
in a local maximum.
PATRICK WINSTON: We might get
stuck in a local maximum.
So, problem letter a is that if
this is your space, it may
look like that.
And you may get stuck
on a local maximum.
Is there any other kind of
problem that can come up?
Well, it all depends on what
the space is like.
Here's a problem where the
space has local maxima.
Now, a lot of people have
been killed on Mt.
Washington when the
fog comes up.
And they do freeze
to death, why?
The reason they freeze to death
is the Hill Climbing
fails them, and they can't
get to the top
to the ranger station.
And the reason is that there
are large lawns on the
shoulders of Mt.
Washington.
It's quite flat.
So, it's the telephone
pole problem.
That space looks like this.
Well, this isn't what Mt.
Washington looks like.
But it's the telephone
pole problem.
So, when you're wandering
around here, the idea of
trying a few directions and
picking the one that's best
doesn't help any, because
it's flat.
That can be a problem
with Hill Climbing.
Now, there's one more problem
with Hill Climbing that most
people don't know about.
But it works like this.
This is a particularly
acute problem in
high dimensional spaces.
I'll illustrate it
here just in two.
And I'm going to switch from
a regular kind of view to a
contour map.
So, my contour map is going to
betray the presence of a sharp
bridge along the
45 degree line.
Now you see how you can
get in trouble there.
You get in trouble, because
if you take a step in each
direction, every direction
takes you downhill.
And you think you're
at the top.
So, suppose you're right
here and you go north.
That takes you down over
a contour line.
If you go south, that
also takes you down
over contour lines.
Likewise, going west and east
all appear to be taking you
down, whereas, in fact, you're
climbing a ridge.
And that contour line is the
highest that I've shown.
So, sometimes you
can get fooled--
not stuck, but fooled-- into
thinking you're at the top
when you're actually not.
Now, this is a model
something.
This subject is about modeling
intelligence.
And this is a kind of algorithm
you frequently need
in order to build an
intelligent system.
But do we have any kind of
Search happening in our heads?
If we're going to model what
goes on inside our heads, do
we have to model any kind of
searching in order to do the
kinds of things that
we humans do?
I suppose so.
Anytime we make a plan, we're
actually evaluating a bunch of
choices and seeing
how they work.
Let me see if I can illustrate
it another way.
This is a system that I showed
you a little bit of last time.
And, shoot, I might as well
review one or two things here.
I showed you a Macbeth story.
This is the story
I showed you.
And if you had this in a
humanities class, the simplest
questions that might be asked
is why did Macduff kill
Macbeth down there
at the bottom?
Did I demonstrate the answering
of questions last
time, or just the development
of the graph?
I can't remember.
But we'll do it again, anyway.
This is somewhat stylized
English.
Just so you'll know,
it doesn't have
to be stylized English.
This is English that's made
available to the Genesis
system by way of something
called Story Workbench.
There's no free lunch.
Either you can use your human
resources to rewrite the plot
in third grade English.
Or you can use your human
resources to take a more
natural, adult-type version of
the story and decorate it with
annotations that make it
possible to absorb it.
Just this summer, in a miracle
of summer [? Europe, ?]
[? Brit ?]
[? van ?]
[? Zijp-- ?]
one of you--
connected these two
systems together.
So, we can now work with stories
that are expressed in
pretty natural English.
Everything in our system is
expressed in English,
including common sense
knowledge--
like if somebody kills
you, you're dead--
but more importantly, for
today's illustration, that
reflective level knowledge,
that knowledge about what
revenge is.
Here you are.
You're in the humanities class,
and someone says,
what's really going
on in the story?
Not the details of who
kills whom, but is
there a Pyrrhic victory?
Does somebody have a success?
Is there an act of revenge?
These are all kinds of things
you might be asked about in
some kind of humanities class.
So, let me fire up the
genesis system.
Pray for internet
connectivity.
Launch the system on a read of
that Macbeth story that I
showed you just a moment ago.
At the moment, it's absorbing
information about background
knowledge, and about reflective
level knowledge,
and all that sort of thing.
It's building itself
this thing we call
an elaboration graph.
It's not quite there yet.
It's still reading background
knowledge.
Now it's reading Macbeth.
It's building it's elaboration
graph, the same thing you saw
last time, except not quite.
Do you see that stuff
down at the bottom?
Those are higher level concepts
that it's managed to
find in the Macbeth story.
So, its found a revenge.
How did it do that?
It searched.
It had a description of what a
revenge is, and it looked to
see if that pattern
was exhibited in
the elaboration graph.
So, in a combination of things
that were said explicitly and
things that were produced by
knee-jerk if/then rules, the
elaboration graph was
sufficiently instantiated that
the revenge pattern
could be found.
That's interesting, Pyrrhic
victory is a little harder.
You'd probably get an a if you
said, oh, there's a Pyrrhic
victory in here.
There it is.
So, I'll blow that up a
little bit so you can
see what that is.
You know what a Pyrrhic
victory is.
It's a situation where
everything seems to be going
good at first, and
then not so hot.
So, Macbeth wants to
be King down here.
And eventually that leads
to becoming King.
But too bad for Macbeth, because
eventually he gets
killed in consequence.
So, it's a Pyrrhic victory.
All that produced by Search
programs who are looking
through this graph.
Now once you've got the
capability of doing that, of
course, then you can find
all sorts of things.
And you can report
them in English.
But, more interestingly, you
can answer questions.
Why did Macbeth--
it cares not a hoot about
capitalization.
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE: On a
common sense level, it looks
like Dr. Jekyll thinks Macduff
killed Macbeth because Macbeth
angered Macduff on a
reflective level.
It looks like Dr. Jekyll thinks
Macduff killed Macbeth
as part of acts of mistake,
Pyrrhic victory, and revenge.
PATRICK WINSTON: Pretty
corny speech output.
But you see the point.
How did it get the stuff on
the common sense level?
The same way all those programs
that build goal trees
report, answers the questions.
It's just looking locally around
in the connections in
the goal tree.
How did it get the stuff on
the reflective level?
By reporting on the searches
that produced information--
it does that by looking for
higher level thoughts about
its own thoughts and reporting
in which of those higher level
thoughts the incident we asked
about actually occurs.
So, let's see, just for fun, we
might be interested in why
Macbeth murdered Duncan.
Wouldn't this be handy if you
hadn't actually read the play,
and here it is, you've got
to write that paper?
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE:
On a common sense
level, it looks like--
PATRICK WINSTON: I'll pull the
plug on that, because that's
just annoying.
Yeah, pretty good, Macbeth wants
to be King, and Duncan
is the King.
Let's see, why did Macbeth
become King?
Oh, it won't answer
the question
unless I spell it right.
I wouldn't be able to show that
to you until last spring.
In fact, I wouldn't have been
able to show you this today
until last week with a
tweak this morning.
Because we've just now connected
the language output
to, of course, [? Cass's ?]
parser system, which is running
in reverse, in order
to generate that English.
So, that's something that has
never before been seen by any
eyes but me.
So, that will conclude what
we have to do today.